kevin du gaming c'est parti aujourd'hui
messieurs dames de notre bon pour jouer
un jeu vidéo ça fait très longtemps je
crois que ça fait plusieurs mois qu'on
n'a pas joué sur la chaîne alors tout
d'abord sachez que j'ai ouvert une
nouvelle chaîne youtube et j'en ai pas
mal et sur cette chaîne là j'ai juste
parlé sur les réseaux sociaux qui
s'appelle squeeze live sur laquelle je
mets des best-of de mes lives y en a
actuellement déjà 8 et ça a l'air
vraiment de vous plaire alors si vous
n'aviez pas entendu parler de la chaîne
puisque je n'ai parlé que sur les
réseaux sociaux et vert foncé vous
abonner regarder les best of et moi vos
retours j'en sors environ deux par
semaine voilà pour ceux qui veulent du
gaming vous êtes servis des amis
aujourd'hui on s'attaque à du lourd du
très très lourd du très très dur sera
pas battu et as tout fraîchement fait le
buzz sur les réseaux sociaux des amis
écoutent et bien je n'ai qu'une parole
écoutez moi bien regarder de moins bien
dans les yeux je suis pas réglé si
aujourd'hui on va terminer le jeu auquel
on joue et ça c'est pas arrivé depuis
longtemps mec c'est un peu comme iv
mario à faire mario vous vous souvenez à
l'époque on y avait joué d'adorer voir
les youtuber souffrir et moi j'adore
souffrir pour vous alors plus tard
d'échangés génial bon j'ai pu j'ai la
flemme de vous expliquer en gros voilà
on joue un petit bonhomme on peut sauter
ou s'accroupir et aller à gauche et à
droite c'est bon en haut à gauche on
peut voir le nombre de vies que j'ai
avant de faire un game over et droz
commencer le jeu du début et en
attendant il ya sûrement des pièges
cachés par ci par là mais voilà comme
ceux comme des pics très original bravo
ça fait plusieurs se fait longtemps je
m'étais pas fait souffrir devant un
petit jeu un mec si je meurs l'oiac pas
de piège ça va être très tendu
c'est bon on y va deuxième niveau ça me
fatigue déjà mais je commence à
connaître les mécaniques tu sais au bout
de six ans de jeu rageant alors la
routine c'est qu'il faut sauter dessus
bonbon quand il revient à l'état alors
les pics qui viennent positive et hop
c'est rigolo nord-ouest souza drôle un
peu et là c'est bon bonjour sl après que
ça me fait rire tellement c'est subtil
et bien fait quoi des mecs à tatataaa on
va retrousser les manches tous ensemble
et on va montrer à ce développeur de
quoi on est capable
[Musique]
alors il ya toi maintenant y'a quoi
aller bas mot ce serait dans le trou
waaa lotion n'a pas besoin de trous nous
quoi alors quand je m'approche de
l'extrémité droite et des pays qui va
dire bonjour alors peut-être qu'il faut
aller à gauche et qu'on peut retourner
dans le niveau d'avant ce qu'en pensera
niveau d'après quelqu'un a compris 100%
c'est ça ok alors regardez bien hop on
va chercher la boule on revient ça fait
trop de trucs et analysé d'un coup mais
qd on compte tous les éléments il faut
prendre en compte mes maquettes mois par
le géant de fer de vidéos comme en 2013
ça me fait très plaisir la boule aulas
et hop ou celle manquée mais chris
morgan a alors nouveau nouvelle assez
comme le jeu wii au cachet plus non mais
où la boule elle via leur monde y est il
faut pas qu'elles touchent l'eau sinon
tu as perdu faut envoyer une boule au
hockey je lai je lai je lèche un tueur
je lai gelé nord donc là en gros elle va
vers le bas et quand je la retouche
attends j'ai rien compris
en fait je crois que dès qu'elle touche
un mur elle change de sens oui c'est ça
regardez la roma elle m'a touché dans
quelles étaient vos à tirer vers le haut
c'est bon j'ai compris dans le bas par
le haut je comprends rien à temps mais
si je descends maintenant aux mecs mais
c'est beau en fait faut juste que je
descende elle fait sa life je suis trop
con oh oui je peux aller en bas il ya
les trucs qui veulent me tuer là bas
elle fait quoi elle fait quoi là
alors je vais juste tester un truc
oh c'était ça il faut juste se colle au
mur à envoyer plein de boules
non il en manque un
on attend je peux y aller oui 1 2 3 4 5
j'ai compris il faut se baser sur un
deux trois soleil c'est le même rythme 1
2 3 soleil voilà tu fais un deux trois
quatre cinq personnes a compris
absolument s'être fc pas alors comment
on fait ok faut que j'arrive y est ça ça
descende là je passe la sas assemblage
pas cela est réputé attend mec ça se
trouve c'est pas là où j'allais je dois
m'assurer que c'est pas ici et tu as un
peu partout
[Musique]
aller pique quand tu crois que tout est
enfin finie evanno on n'a plus qu'une
vie j'aimerais au moins comprend la
mécanique de ce nobel pour la prochaine
fois alors petit sous-marin petit game
over
allez je veux ma soucoupe qui lâchent
des bombes alors faire gaffe aux bombes
mais exposerait les hardcore à mais je
sais faut se mettre au dessus du vide en
fait du coup il faut prendre ça et je
savais que la all bat les beats le pic
nous bloque donc je pense qu'il faut
qu'on berne le pic comme stéphane ont
regardé à [ __ ] et on y est oh oui oh
oui oh non c'est beau aller à droite on
est qu'on va y arriver
star fout là on y arrive won han mec
mecs dans mais se plaît qua non mais je
veux pas voir un game over de quoi ça me
plairait trop à aa
oh pardon excusez moi excusez moi c'est
pour l'esprit malin non aurier
s'abstenir fauche calcul est bon ça va
rater allons lancer paris je parie 10
euros que je rate si je rate pas je dois
10 euros voient 10 millions non je
change de paris je donne 500 euros à une
association
si je réussis je le fais vraiment tout
de suite bravo connard au attend quoi ah
ok faut péter les mureaux qu'il faut se
placer de manière répétée les murs ouais
c'est ça non je me sois riespach aller
de vie de vie on peut finir le jeu avec
deux finalement qu'est-ce que ces deux
vies dans une vie un laissé tomber là il
faut avancer la fourrure décalé et là
c'est bon au mec je suis trop chaud
allez on a devient préfet a demandé des
bons envoyés là je commence à avoir un
petit qu'il a un coût tout comprendre du
coup j'ai vraiment du plaisir et jouer
allez c'est maintenant aux mecs je pense
qu'un s'approche vraiment de la fin du
jeu leven 11 on adore regarder donc là
il faut tout calculer c'est ça et je
parie que ça glisse en plus la surface
ah oui
fils de [ __ ] on aura pratiqué c'est pas
grave on a pratiqué on va à se rassurer
en disant qu' on a pratiqué je
n'arriverai jamais à temps je crois que
en fait le dernier qu'il se ok d'accord
dès que je touchais un cube en glace le
dernier quelques voiliers à droite
diminuant taille car mon avis il ya un
cube que je peux éviter mais lequel
eh ben on sera peut-être plus tard
[Musique]
bonjour je suis à dix on finir un jeu
d'imagés
en plus la fédé
je
suite
mais papa ben hur
ap
c'est quelqu'un d'unique jeter dans deux
enfants
passion vérité jamais deux sans trois
bouger
j'ai couru dans un trou
je suis sorti deux noms
et à chaque fois c'est la même chose par
la game débat des eaux
c'est la fin des soir
c'est aussi l'espoir
iv
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les cages et du sud
à chaque fois désolé
je fais encore c'est ce côté
je vous réserve
[Applaudissements]
des chars mais je m'adapte
[Musique]
les amis je suis arrivé au niveau il ya
les petits éclairs de merde vous rendez
pas compte à quel point ces besoins le
plus dur auquel vous avez joué mais
vraiment pour de vrai je pense qu'on
doit être à la moitié la plus tard à
laisser maintenant on dire
[Musique]
mais je les passais c'est gros j'ai
envie de pleurer
alors ça glisse faut faire quoi on se
baisse on se baisse 11 baisse 11 belle
merde
laisse moi au moins voir si je suis
proche de la faim ou pas c'est ça qu'il
faut savoir aujourd'hui mais je
pencherais aux deux tiers un vrai gros
le jeu est gratuit le mec serait pas
fait chez à ce point ma première
réussite 12 minutes 11 attend ça c'est
qu'à une minute dix de son [ __ ]
monstres ou non mais ils le font en
boucle moi j'en suis là voilà quoi ça
c'est qu'une minute 50 sur douze minutes
10 ça veut dire que je suis gamin s'il
ya du jeu puisqu'il faut bien rire
pleurer pour faire quoi là dans cette
situation water makes team et d'en être
arrivé là je croyais avoir fait mieux
que tous les autres que tu veux au pq
comme
[Musique]
les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
l'échec extrêmement dur à avaler mais ça
fait deux heures et demi que je suis
dessus et je suis qu'à un quart bon les
amis je vous parle sérieusement si vous
voulez un deuxième épisode n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo à me dire en commentaire
que je sache parce que là si je tourne
un deuxième épisode ça veut dire que je
dois retourner cette heure parce qu'à
chaque fois qu'on va perdre toutes nos
vies moi je vais devoir tout me retaper
ça ce sera que tu es au montage mais ça
va être une journée entière à jouer à ce
jeu je suis prêt à le faire
il faut que ça vaille le coup parce que
mec déjà l'attaquant logiquement je suis
dans un net
alors dites moi et on se retrouve
bientôt cette vidéo je m'en vais sauter
du cinquième étage au revoir
[Musique]
ça